I can't wait for you guys to see my new
show on DC Universe you're gonna piss
yourself I promise I think they're gonna
hate it harls they hate everything no
way it's got comedy action incredibly
gratuitous violence and unlike that
Deadpool cartoon it's actually coming
out I thought we were supposed to make a
show that was like super gritty and
bleak and depressing you know like a DC
thing that is an excellent way to make
television and film but every one of my
shows gonna have fun or I will bash them
there's no fun in Arkham Quinton except
him yeah the guy's a real buzzkill oh I
like it you're gonna hate it
hey everybody is Charlie surprise
surprise they dropped the trailer for
the Harley Quinn TV show so we got to
break it down there's also a whole bunch
of other news for the DC Universe like
they just announced that Matt Bomer is
gonna be- man for Doom Patrol for all
you big Red Hood fans the actor that
plays Robin explained what they're doing
with Jason Todd so I'll tag a clip of
that interview later in the video too
because it's New York Comic Con week
there's a bunch of trailers happening if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos it's
gonna be crazy so if you guys have no
idea what's going on there's a Harley
Quinn animated TV show that's gonna
premiere next year after Young Justice
is done on DC Universe although because
Netflix just bought the international
distribution rights for Titans I'm kind
of expecting them to do that with the
other DC Universe shows at least for the
next year or so they make that
determination every time they have a new
show so they have to go into
negotiations for a Young Justice
distribution they'll have to do the same
thing for this Harley Quinn TV show in
the Doom Patrol TV show you probably
recognize some of the voices Harley
Quinn is actually Kaley Cuoco from Big
Bang Theory poison ivy is being played
by Lake Bell and Dietrich Bader is doing
Batman you probably recognize his voice
he did it during brave in the bold and a
couple of the animated movies so
obviously this is just a couple of the
characters animation doesn't really have
the same rules and restrictions when it
comes to the characters that they can
use but the cell that they're in is
Arkham Asylum the symbol on their
jackets is actually the Arkham symbol
from the Batman Arkham games - like you
probably notice a couple Easter eggs and
then obviously a whole bunch of jokes
and references making fun of a bunch of
different things particularly themselves
as DC but they also take a big swipe at
Deadpool if you look in the background
you can see that Harley Quinn has pasted
the Joker's face on some dudes body when
poison ivy says pretty sure they're
gonna hate it that's what they do
they're making that meta reference to
everyone just hating on DC because of
all the stuff that's been happening in
the last year so the joke about the
Deadpool TV series is actually a much
longer story I've done a separate video
about what happened to that because
Donald Glover was making a Deadpool
animated series on the FX network it was
going to be great they had all this
crazy stuff going on then everything got
quiet earlier this spring when we hit
the actual expected release date they
issued a statement saying
that FX had passed on the project but
then after that Donald Glover released
this giant meta script which actually
wasn't a real script it was more him
commenting on the situation about how
Marvel wasn't really comfortable with
all the people that they were taking
shots out losing the character like
Deadpool makes fun of people but
apparently they were making all kinds of
jokes that Marvel didn't like and they
didn't like the way that their scripts
were playing out so officially Marvel
television in Jeph Loeb are the people
that pulled the plug on the Deadpool
animated series it was actually gonna be
really badass it was a big
disappointment but this is them just
joking about that unlike that Deadpool
TV series this is actually gonna come
out they haven't given a specific
release date but it's gonna be after
Young Justice airs at least half of its
season or at least 13 episodes so I'm
guessing either spring or summer of next
year but according to the cast I'm just
gonna read the news release here the
series begins with Harley breaking up
with the Joker after he screws her over
seems pretty common situation between
the two of them in deciding to strike
out on her own over the course of the
first season we'll see her try to become
the best badass super villain that there
is in she'll cross paths with dr. psycho
Batman Lex Luthor Wonder Woman and of
course poison ivy so they're actually
going beyond the Batman catalog of
characters Alan Tudyk is gonna be part
of the cast they didn't say which
character he'll be voicing though he's
actually done a whole bunch of DC series
in the past Ron Funches JB Smoove Jason
Alexander from Seinfeld is gonna be a
character don't know who he's gonna play
Wanda Sykes Giancarlo Esposito Gus fring
from Breaking Bad Natalie Morales Jim
rash diedrich bader like I mentioned
Tony Hale and Chris Bologna from Law &
Order so what they'll probably do is
release a bigger Longer trailer once
they have some animation done but they
only announced the project a little
while ago so they probably don't have
that many episodes like it took them a
while to finish Young Justice episodes
and they're still not completely done
with season 3 that's probably why
they're not premiering it till January
but the whole deal with this DC
streaming service is that they air
episodes weekly so they're not gonna
drop a new TV series like Young Justice
for instance until they get done airing
all twelve Titans episodes they're
announcing a whole bunch of DC Universe
TV show related news at New York Comic
Con this week like they just announced
that Matt
is gonna be playing negative man on the
Doom Patrol TV show remember Brendan
Fraser is doing the voice for robot man
there's a different actor that's playing
the actual physical person walking
around on set Timothy freakin Dalton is
gonna be playing the chief and it's
gonna be based on Grant Morrison's Doom
Patrol run so it's gonna be crazy it's
weird how many big actors they're
getting for this series but we don't
have a trailer for that yet they're
still shooting it so we'll probably get
a trailer for that sometime later this
year I'm not expecting any footage
anytime soon the dew Patrol TV show is
connected to Titans remember they're
introducing cyborg because he's a Teen
Titans core member he's gonna debut on
the Doom Patrol TV show then I think in
a future season you'll see him crossover
and become a member of the Titans but I
have seen the first couple of episodes
of Titans so I'm allowed to post my
non-spoilery review tomorrow morning
that's Thursday morning so that's when
that'll be up here's that clip of Robin
explaining what they're doing with Jason
Todd this season Jason Todd has become a
replacement for Dick Grayson so he has
fulfilled my position working with
Batman so there's a little bit of
tension in in the scenes where we meet
because I have left I've left for a
reason like I was saying it's not the
way of fighting crime that I believe in
and Jason Todd is what I think being
brainwashed by Batman to believe that
you know this brutal destructive
murderous in a way way of fighting crime
isn't right so there's a little bit of
tension in me trying to teach him to you
know to right those wrongs and to you
know not do everything he says you know
those scenes
I think episode 7 is when he comes in
we're really fun they they were very
banter II and and you know there's a
part of Dick Grayson for sure that
misses that way of life that you know
that kind of wishes he could get a
little touch of you know what it was
like to fight crime with Batman but at
the end of the day he sticks to his
belief and really you know fights for
what he believes in and tries to find
his own there's a whole bunch of other
comic book related stuff happening this
week daredevil season 3 is probably
going to drop another big trailer
because that's premiering in a couple
more weeks there's also a whole bunch of
spider-man
from home news I was gonna do a video
about that till they dropped this
footage so I just prioritized this I'll
do spider-man tomorrow don't worry I'll
also do some venom postmortem
I'll be doing venom Easter eggs and
post-credit scenes and all that stuff
this weekend be sure to go see the movie
so that we can talk about it I've
already posted my non-spoilery review
and I'll be doing DC and Marvel giveaway
stuff in those respective videos so just
look out for all that stuff as long as
you have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll see all the videos when I post
them so no worries but click here for my
non-spoilery venom review and click here
for a brand new flash trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]